Всіх вітаю два дні відбувалися пленарні
засідання Верховної Ради України Шкода
що українці сьогодні мало знають про
роботу парламенту адже трансляції не
відбуваються і тут питання не тільки в
безпеці а в тому що канал Рада
рейдернула Банкова і це звичайно
неправильно адже наше платники податків
українці мають право слідкувати за
роботою законодавчого органу ці дні
відбувалися важливі голосування в першу
чергу продовжено ще на три місяці
воєнний стан і мобілізація очевидно що
попри побідобійсія про яке так люблять
розповідати дивані експерти насправді до
перемоги ще довгий і важкий шлях і нам
разом треба зосередитися на тому щоб
Україна досягла перемога якнайшвидше
тому наша політична команда наполягає на
тому щоб
робота Верховної Ради була зосереджена в
першу чергу навколо законів що
стосується підтримки армії це
ненормально що сьогодні в Збройних силах
України у силах тир оборони забрали оці
доплати 30 тисяч гривень і військові
просто з цього приводу посилають дуже
негативні сигнали мій телефон телефон
моїх колег просто червоні від обурення
тому що так на передовій на першій лінії
фронту залишається виплати 100 тисяч але
коли бригади батальйони підрозділи
тероборони відправляються на ротацію на
відновлення на злагодження падає
зарплата до 14-20 тисяч очевидно що це є
ненормальна оплата труда-воїна за ці
гроші не можна отримати родину за ці
кошти дуже часто військові самі купують
собі форму знаряддя і такого бути не
може Ми якраз вносимо пропозицію щодо
повернення виплат 30 тисяч тих і якщо
треба заощаджувати в цьому скупому
такому скудному збірному українському
бюджеті то є на чому поощаджувати той
самий Марафон на який йдуть мільярди той
самий російськомовні канали дом Freedom
який ніхто не дивиться на них ідуть
мільярди от на цьому можна заощаджувати
також дуже важливо що парламент прийняв
низку кадрових рішень зокрема Василь
малюк уже не в О він повноцінний Голова
служби безпеки України в своєму
зверненні до парламенту малюк заявив що
служба безпеки зосереджена сьогодні на
контррозвідці і боротьбі з зовнішнім і
внутрішнім ворогом дуже правильні слова
і я вважаю що парламент тут в першу
чергу має допомогти службу безпеці
України в тому щоб ліквідувати цю
Московську церкву тому що люди в цих
рясах насправді не з хрестами дуже часто
на пузі а підсимирясами вони там носять
ординамі далі російської Федерации вот
це церква має бути ліквідована
відповідні законопроекти зареєстровані в
парламенті питання тільки їх поставити в
порядок денний так говоримо правильне
рішення щодо заборони цих проросійських
партій але як депутати залишаються і в
парламенті і місцевих органах ради і З
цим треба щось робити не просто говорити
не просто там
позбавили мандату і люди поїхали собі
далі в батальйон Монако розважатися А де
політична відповідальність досі
залишається представники упсж
керівниками комітетів заступниками
комітетів там керівників вони формують
нові групи Звичайно Це ненормально Це
питання теж має бути вирішено так само
Ігор Клименко став керівником
Міністерства внутрішніх справ після
такої трагічної загибелі шановного і
хорошого чудової людини Дениса
Монастирського сьогодні очевидно що
потрібно було вирішити це кадрове
питання Міністерстві Внутрішніх справ
європейська Солідарність не голосує за
кадрові рішення влади Ми не можемо брати
на себе відповідальність за них але від
щирого серця бажаємо новим керівникам
успіхів дуже важливих посадах і звичайно
ми готові співпрацювати по всіх питаннях
які стосуються захисту територіальної
цілісності і суверенітету України з
надважливого голосування це нарешті
нарешті після 11 місяців такої боротьби
і постійних криків цього приводу у нас
спрощена процедура імпорту Дронів і
інших важливих знарядь для збройних сил
України забрали ПДВ цих товарів дуже
важливих так само в першому читанні
прийнято закон щодо прозорості
закупівель Міністерства оборони очевидно
що ці речі які складають де ж таємницю і
можуть слугувати там ворогу для певної
чутливої інформації мають бути закриті
але вартість куриного яйця ну це точно
не є державною таємницею і вона має бути
публічною до речі сьогодні в буфеті
Верховної Ради спеціально купила яйце
воно тут коштує 15 грн тобто дешевше 17
і це показово А так само з
законопроектів по яким Ну ми вважаємо
неправильні були голосування там є
великі ризики це зміни до бюджету які ми
по суті знову обнулюють парламент і
дозволяють міністерству фінансів а самим
без участі вже в Верховній Раді
розпоряджатися залишками грантів або
запозичених коштів наших міжнародних
партнерів і перекидати їх з одних
програм на інше очевидно що тут можуть
бути корупційні ризики кілька важливих
голосувань заяв Верховної Ради України
зокрема група Вагнер нарешті визнана
терористичною організацією нагадаю заяву
цю європейська Солідарність
зареєструвала в парламенті три роки тому
але вона чекала свого часу аж поки наші
американські партнери конгрес - це над
невизнали вагнерівців терористичної
організації ну і тут от знову відбулося
цікаве в Верховній раді коли неправильні
автори у постанови коли там є депутати
від солідарності та слуги її переписують
і Пані безугла да да безугла внесла таку
Постанову в парламент але ми наполягли
на тому щоби наше так само була
розглянута постанова адже в ній ідеться
не тільки про вагнерівців А про ці
приватні армії які сьогодні створюють
російські силовики які На жаль стали
частиною цієї армії вбив взагалі Україна
має бути лідером в оцінці того що
російські Варвари і вбивці творять на
нашій території задавати тут тон а не
порівняти такі важливі рішення вже після
наших партнерів Ну і так само ми
звернулися від парламенту до
Міністерства до Міжнародного
олімпійського комітету щодо виключення
російських які білоруських спортсменів з
міжнародних змагань тому що більшість
цих спортсменів є військовослужбовцями
діючими і вони належать до армії вбивць
і так само звертаємося до
парламентського асамблеї ОБСЄ щодо
виключення Росії з цієї організації
Він має понести покарання на всіх
міжнародних майданчиках над цим ми
працюємо ну власне так само продовжуємо
робити все для того щоб парламент був
прозорим його діяльність щоб була відома
е-е народу України тому що це вперше за
30 років взагалі така закритість роботи
парламенту і знову це звичайно нема
нічого спільного з воєнним станом Це
просто політична цензура яка
неприпустимою для країни яка рухається в
бік єсената ми обов'язково там будемо в
першу чергу завдяки найкращим стилю
збройним силам України це буде Україна